as he gets close he gives the orders to
fire and washington is shrouded in smoke
and the smoke was cleared and washed and
was still walking toward the british on
his horse
[Music]
what kind of virtuous courage moral
doing right moral doing virtue and uh
courage is a great place to start
because it's uh vivid
everybody knows you don't want to get
killed you know if you can get your
druthers you're not going to be tortured
and so the occasions where that's at
risk
are real tests real human tests
uh you know jesus says a greater love
has no man
than to give up his life for his friend
right what makes a courageous act
right disposition towards fear and
confidence
and you have to do it for the sake of
the beautiful so
explain about right disposition
fear and confidence why why are fear and
confidence opposites courage is about
finding the
the mean condition between a healthy
awareness of your fear and your
confidence that
allows you to stay and fight the battle
without throwing away your life
unnecessarily as the rash person does
so all these virtues moral virtues all
the doing virtues have
a mean between two extremes and i think
kate asks a good question we talked
about
a long time yesterday about how do you
calculate where the middle is
and the answer is first you identify
what the extremes are
and so rashness means what
uh rashes means in excess of confidence
where
you aren't afraid of anything and you'll
just throw yourself
into the battle whatever happens and uh
the opposite is cowardice and we know
what that means
right and so you're going to be in
between there
would a fully virtuous person
be making that calculation in those
terms at the time
what would they be thinking about the
end
the goal george washington at the battle
of princeton is a really great story
uh because he had won in trenton
you know the christmas morning they went
across the delaware
because they'd just been getting
hammered for months and they needed to
win
something in the first year of the war
and he
surprised the hessians and he killed a
bunch of them and he took
trenton but cornwallis is coming down
with a bigger force
at princeton down new jersey and uh
washington sees that i can't really be
driven out of here
in a single day that'll deprive us of
the prestige of the victory
so he had to go up there and fight and
when he got up there the american troops
were running
and he walked his horse through them
and didn't look left or right
and he just kept walking toward the
british and his adjutant
records that washington couldn't have
known if anybody had come with him
as he gets close he gives the orders to
fire
you know and and there's a volley and
washington is shrouded in smoke
and fitzwilliam put his cap down over
his face he couldn't
stand to see the fall in washington then
he picked it up and the smoke was
cleared and washed and was still walking
toward the british on his horse
and the and the americans had formed up
behind him
and they ran the british away and that's
one reason why
george washington is the father of our
country
people saw that and they thought
i can trust this man that
is the human being in action
body and soul and it's
fully realized in that moment
and that is the epitome of
moral action which involves thinking
and decisions too and
and where's the heart of it where's the
thing that makes it
a true virtue to washington is it that
he didn't get shot
is it that they won the battle is it
what
it's in what he wanted
the motive is all important what do you
want
and what you want by the way
is supremely to do
[Music]
with practice especially through the
doing virtues
but not only george washington i will
say
you know he wrote out these rules of
civil
behavior and so when he was a little boy
he was
practicing all the time and the rules of
civil
behavior include don't bite your nails
don't spit when you talk
the last one is labor to keep alive
in your breast the celestial
fire known as honor i think he says i
can't remember saying
memories found me but that means that
he intended to develop the ability to do
that
and the way he developed it was by
making
good choices when there's
reason not to make them
i'm larry iron president of hillsdale
college you will find if you look at our
online courses that they cover the whole
range
of human learning all the high and
fundamental things
everyone needs to know they are free
because we have always wished
to provide sound learning to anyone who
wishes to have it